at the palace of discovery in Paris they
have this huge turntable where you can
sit and perform experiments like in the
middle of the turntable you can put some
water and then add liquid nitrogen and
this creates a kind of fog these tiny
water droplets that spread out from the
middle but because the actual linear
speed of this turntable is increasing
the further out you go
well the vapor falls further and further
behind creating a swirl that looks a
little bit like a hurricane and that
analogy is not by accident the earth is
after all one giant turntable and the
weather patterns we get are a result of
that when you study physics in rotating
frames of reference or even just
rotating bodies you find some pretty
mysterious and counterintuitive
phenomena which is why I'm dedicating
this video to four revolutionary riddles
number one here I have a ramp or an
inclined plane and just to show you I'm
not doing anything funny with it if I
just let a roll of tape go it will
accelerate down the ramp but here I have
a mystery cylinder and I'm gonna place
that on the ramp and we will see that it
rolls and then it stops and then it
rolls and then stops so my question to
you is what is in the mystery cylinder
what is this object number two take a
bicycle and have someone support it so
it doesn't fall over or lean it up
against something and then take a bit of
string and tie it to the bottom pedal
now what I'm gonna do is pull backwards
horizontally on this string and I want
you to predict what the bike will do
will it go backwards forwards or will it
just stay there and not move my
intuition would tell me that would go
forward I think it might not move if
you're gonna be pulling backwards from a
stationary point
the petal you're gonna be pulling it
backwards just as the petals are trying
to spin the wheels forward so maybe it
might not move I think it's gonna go
forward I'll go with the forward sure
yeah I'm sure all right number three I
want you to think about running two laps
of this track now the first lap you can
go as slowly as you like let's call that
speed v1 but on your second lap I want
you to run faster such that the total
average speed for both laps combined is
twice v1 twice the speed of your first
lap so the question for you is how fast
you have to run that second lap so that
your total average speed is 2 v1 number
for any time a train is moving either
slowly or very fast there is a part of
the train which is actually moving
backwards with respect to the ground
that is not backwards with respect to
the train and it doesn't have to be
going so slowly that if you ran
backwards you would be going backwards
with respect to the ground it is at any
speed any normal train will have a part
of it which is moving backwards with
respect to the ground my question to you
is which part is it now with these four
riddles you can make me a video response
if you like to tell me about your
solutions to them or you can simply
leave your answers in the comments below
and number them 1 2 3 4 so we know which
ones you're talking about and I will
post all of the answers up and next week
at the same time same place all of my
videos are made possible by my patrons
on patreon so if you are one of those
people thank you so much for your
ongoing support and if you're not maybe
now is a good time to consider becoming
one if you go to patreon.com slash
veritasium you can support me there
otherwise if you're interested in more
riddley puzzly things you can check out
my spinning tube trick my 5 fun physics
phenomena and say the spinning district
and if you haven't subscribed veritasium
already I highly recommend you do that
and since I'll be posting the answers
next week I would like for you to ring
the bell
down below and that will make sure that
you're notified when my videos come out
so as always thanks for watching
wait that's that's Michael's line